hi
welcome to openjs we're going to talk
about javascript to grumpy parts
javascript is kind of weird but well
let's dig in and see how it works and
see if we can understand why it's weird
and make it a little bit less mysterious
here's the part where i tell you i'm
definitely going to post the slides on
my site tonight
and well they're already there i've been
the person chasing the
the st speaker as well and yeah here's
javascript grumpy parts
the slides are online right now while
you're here on robrich.org
click on about me and you'll get to this
spot that talks a little bit about the
things that i do
i'm a microsoft mvp a friend of redgate
a cyril developer evangelist
and let me tell you about azgiv camp az
give camp brings volunteer developers
together with charities to build free
software we start friday after work
sunday afternoon we deliver that
completed software to the charities
sleep is optional caffeine provided if
you're in phoenix
come join us for the next azgive camp or
if you'd like a gift camp where you're
connecting from
hit me up on email or on twitter and
let's get a gift camp in your
neighborhood too
some of the other things that i've done
i worked on the gulp team as a core
contributor in version two in version
three
and dot net rocks i replied to a.net
rocks podcast episode they read my
comment on the air and they sent me a
mug
so there's my claim to fame my
coveted.net rocksmug
so let's dig into javascript the grumpy
parts
now we will need to go a little fast
because well we only have a half hour
together
but i would like to thank john mills he
has a talk
a jo a guide to javascript scary side
that helped inspire this talk
now he goes into different directions
but his talk is
amazing and so if you have a chance
listen to him as well
we'll probably hit the end of my
knowledge and that'll be really fun i
look forward to
the part where i say i don't know
in the beginning brendan ike
created javascript in 10 days
25 years ago i've written some code 25
years ago and it was pretty awful
and yet here we all are talking about
javascript brendan did an
amazing job if you'd like to learn more
about brendan read more or watch more to
see
how he invented javascript it's really
cool each of these blue links in the
slides here from rawritch.org
are links to be able to dial into
additional information
now what's really cool is we now have a
bunch of javascript engines that are for
the most part
really high fidelity in v8 we have
chrome
in spider monkey we have firefox in uh
in internet explorer we have chakra in
safari we have javascript core
and each of these javascript engines
works
pretty much the same brendan ike's
library was cloned with amazing fidelity
now we talk about differences between
javascript in different browsers
html5 has made that a little bit less of
a concern
but that was about our interaction with
the document object model the dom
the javascript runtime itself is
amazingly compatible
including all the bugs
so javascript was copied with incredible
precision
including the bugs let's take a look at
some of the weird things
now some of the major design goals of
this language was it was a language that
well
runs over there when we develop
javascript we ship our source code
a js file the browser is the one that
compiles that js code into
executable and runs it now that isn't
quite right but we can use that analogy
it runs over there after the developer
has left so one of its primary
objectives is to keep running as often
as possible
now if it keeps running
it's going to try to be as forgiving as
possible so
well if it notices a syntax error it
will back up and see if it can put a
semicolon in to be able to solve that
now are semicolons required in
javascript
well yes they are but the engine may
insert them automatically
so if you see javascript without
semicolons
that's why we're leveraging that piece
of the compiler that says hey let me fix
that for you
so let's take a look at some of the
weird things in javascript
this is the javascript watt talk and i'm
not going to play it for you but i
invite you to grab
these slides from robrich.org and click
play what's particularly cool is this is
brendan ike
playing the javascript wet talk at one
of his talks
and his commentary throughout it it is
amazing
so let's take a look at some weird
things undefined well
undefined is just a variable so what if
we
define it in more recent versions of
javascript of ecmascript it is defined
as a constant so we can't override it
but this led to some really really
interesting bugs if
so for example we defined javascript
type of null type of null is an object
hmm should it be null should it be an
object
this is probably one of those bugs
brenda knight created it in 10 days and
a few weeks after that he said you know
there's some bugs here i'd like to come
back and fix
and he was told hey there's 40
developers already building with
javascript right now
we need to not change it that would be
backwards incompatible
40 developers hmm i bet there's 40
developers in this room that
wish we had gone back and fixed it but
he made the best decision that he could
at the time
here's another one type of nan well not
a number
is well a number
i get that not a number is kind of in
the number group
it's more in the number group than say
in the date group or the object group or
the function group
but not a number being a number yeah
that's kind of weird
so these are some of the weird things in
javascript and let's see if we can dig
in
and understand how they came to be and
why they are that way now first up let's
take a look at the javascript compiler
now i grant that in modern javascript
engines we have mechanisms for
code spl uh tree shaking and
just in time compilation and those are
amazing but at its core
javascript is a two phase compiler the
first phase goes and looks for
variable declarations and it kind of
sets aside that memory for those
variables the next phase is to run the
code
now because javascript has this two
phase compiler
then we can use that knowledge to
understand some code
and really dig in deep if you'd like to
learn more about the two-phase compiler
i would invite you to click through
to the slides at robrich.org and click
to read more or watch more
so let's take a look at this code what's
it going to do
let's think like the compiler and see if
we can figure it out
now the first phase we go look for
variable declarations
here's one var foo equals bar okay so
we're not setting it to bar yet that
would be the execution phase
but we are declaring this variable varfu
next phase let's go execute the code so
we start out declaring this function
then we'll call it so we'll start off
and we'll console log foo
well we already have this foo variable
declared
we haven't set its value yet so we get
undefined
if true now variables in javascript by
default
are function scoped not curly brace
scoped
so we know that this foo variable exists
out here
now we're going to set it to bar and
then we'll leave the curly braces this
variable
continues on and we console log bar so
we get undefined
and bar so in our minds we've kind of
tricked ourselves to
believing that the variables get hoisted
it makes sense to believe that well we
just kind of moved this variable
declaration up here and we set it to
undefined
now that variable hoisting is a cool lie
that we tell ourselves but that's not
actually how it works how it works is
this two phase compiler
yes variable hoisting it's a lie
it's a convenient lie and it helps us to
think about this
in kind of a more synchronous way
without having to separate that
two-phase
compiler mechanism now that's
interesting but
well it is a lie it's a very convenient
lie and i like it
but hoisting is a lie
so as we think like the compiler we can
see how that variable hoisting
it isn't actually moved rather it's
well it's a two-phase compiler
so we saw this code and we saw how we
could execute it in interesting ways
let's take a look at defining and not
defining variables in various scopes
now we had a mechanism before where we
declared some foo variables
let's declare this foo variable and this
foo variable
take a minute to pause the video and
think through this
what will it do
now let's think like the compiler and
figure it out first phase
we go look for variable declarations we
find this one
foo so let's declare that one we find
this one let's declare that one
now variables are declared with function
scope so
we have two different foo variables in
different scopes
an inner foo and an outer foo if you
will now
second phase let's run the code so let's
take this outer foo and set it to bar
we'll declare this function we'll call
that function
and now we declare this inner foo and
set it to baz
now if true now the curly braces don't
define scope in javascript
variables are scoped to functions so we
go looking for this foo variable to set
it to bam
is there a food variable in the scope
yes there is right here foo
so we set it from baz to bam and we'll
console log bam
we leave the curly brace scope functions
are
functions to find the scope and so now
we cancel log foo
and we get this bam again we leave our
function and now we need to find this
outer variable is there a variable
defined in this scope
yes there is right here so we'll output
bam
bam and bar is that what you got
let's change this up a little bit
instead of declaring the variable here
let's declare it here stop the video
here
how does this work let's think like the
compiler and figure it out our first
phase is to define all of the variables
define this one to find that one and the
second phase is to execute this
so we'll set our outer food to bar we'll
call our
function set our inner food to baths
wait a minute
where do we get this in our food well we
go looking for variables in the current
scope
here's one this variable is defined as
a function based variable so we'll set
it to baz
then we'll set it to bam we'll console
log bam we'll cancel log bam again
and as we leave the function then we
console log bar
bam bam bar is that what you got
let's do it again but instead we won't
declare these variables at all
okay first step let's go look for
variables to declare here's a variable
let's declare that one
second phase let's go execute it okay so
let's set this variable to bar
let's call our function now we go
looking for a food variable
is there a food variable in the current
scope there isn't
so we walk up scopes javascript is
trying to help us of course the
code is running over there once the user
once the developer has left
so we go looking up scopes oh here's a
foo variable let's use this one
so where it was bar it is now baz
let's do that again and where it was
bazz it is now bam
so we'll console log bam and bam as we
leave our function
we now console log the foo in the outer
scope do we have a foo in this outer
scope
yes we have this one that we set to bam
so we get bam
bam bam flintstones
let's do it again but in this case let's
not declare it at all
pause the video and figure out what
happens here
now let's think like the compiler and
figure it out first phase
let's go define all of our variables
there aren't any
second phase let's go execute so foo
equals bar is there a food variable in
the scope there isn't
let's climb up the scope well in this
case
we'll climb all the way up to the global
scope and we will define a variable
there
javascript is trying to help us succeed
and so we define a global variable
foo and set its value to bar
now let's call our function do we have a
foo variable set in this scope
we don't so let's climb up the scopes
until we get to that global variable
that we built for here
and we'll set that to baz
let's go find that variable again set it
to bam bam
bam we leave here and we log bam again
now that's interesting javascript helped
us by declaring a global variable
but well what if that variable was
called i
and what if you used it and i used it
now we may
overwrite each other it is after all a
global variable javascript tried to help
our code succeed
but it may have done us a disservice by
just automatically creating a variable
let's do this again but now let's set
foo to bam
pause the video here see what happens
now let's think like the compiler and
figure it out first step
let's define this foo variable second
step let's execute
we'll set foo to bar we'll call our
function
foo is there a foo defined in this scope
there is not
okay here's a foo so let's set it from
bar to baz
now we'll set it to bam is there a bam
variable defined in here
there is not how about in this scope
nope
let's keep climbing up the scopes until
we find it well we didn't find it
so how do we get its variable its value
we don't have a variable to get its
value out of so we get
a reference error bam is not defined now
we could
set a new variable correctly but we
could not get a new variable
yeah that is kind of weird but as we
think like the compiler
it makes sense we can't read from a
variable that doesn't exist
but javascript is going to try to help
our code succeed
so it will go create variables and set
them if they aren't defined
almost being equal i'd rather it just
through an exception
well kind of i'd rather it through an
exception while i was developing it but
out there in the wild
yeah i'd rather my user be able to
continue on as much as they could
so let's do it again now we've defined
variables here
with var but let's switch it up to let
now let is new in es6 or es2015 and let
is defined as bound to curly braces
instead of bound to function scope
pause pause the video here and see what
happens
now let's think like the compiler and
figure it out first
we need to go define all of our
variables here's one
and here's one next let's execute let's
set the outer food to bar
then let's call our function
now we're looking for a foo variable is
there a food variable defined in this
scope
no this let means that this variable is
defined to an inner scope
so we go looking for another foo
variable in an outer scope oh there's
one right here
so we'll change it from bar to baz
then inside of our if block let's create
a new variable and we'll set that to bam
so let's console log bam inside here
then let's console.log
this variable we don't have one defined
in this scope
but we have one defined in the outer
scope so here we will output
baz bam baz and then out here we're
looking for this variable and we'll
output baz again
bam baz baz great
now let's not define the variable
okay let's think like the compiler and
see if we can figure it out
first we declare our all our variables
there's just one right here
second we'll execute we'll call our
function
we'll go looking for a variable there
isn't one in this scope there isn't one
in the outer scope so we define a new
global variable called foo
and set its value to baz inside this if
block we have this
curly brace scoped variable so we output
bam and then
baz and then out here we go looking for
a variable in the current scope
we don't find it we climb up the tree
until we get to that same global
variable defined here
and we output paths wait a minute
did this variable leak outside the
function
well yeah because we didn't define it
scoped to anything
it was created as a global variable
that's weird
but well javascript helped us and when
it helped us
it created a mechanism where our code
would continue to run
even if it's in a little bit of an
unexpected way
let's do it again but let's define these
two variables here
what happens in this case let's think
like the compiler
well everything works well inside this
function
once we get out here we're going to get
to this foo variable and we're going to
go look for a global foo variable
well there's no variable defined in this
scope let's keep looking for a global
variable
nothing was defined here because all
these variables were defined
so we get a reference area
foo is not defined foo is not defined
because
well because i defined these variables
inside this containing function then
they expired once we left that
scope let's do it again but let's switch
from
let to const now const in es6
is a variable that can't change now the
contents of that object
can change but the variable itself
cannot
so let's dig in and take a look
well we define our variable
we call into our function and now we're
looking for a variable
called foo in the current scope this one
is an inner scope so we can't grab that
one so we go looking for this outer
scope
and we go try to set it ooh we can't set
a constant so we get assignment to a
constant variable
now if we're using babel to transpile
from es6 to es5
where const doesn't exist then it
changes this const to a let
or no it changes a const to a var and
yes we can assign a var
so we'll get different behavior every
evergreen browser
supports es6 or better now so probably
we want to turn down babel to
output es6 or better and ensure that
that const is indeed const
but that's why you might get different
behavior inside of
babel so we took a look at defining
variables let's take a look
at this what is this
well it's the thing to the left of the
dot
let's take a look at some examples and
we have this speak function where we
console.log
this dot name now we're defining name
out here in a global way
well global to this space so if we call
speak
what is the thing to the left of the dot
well global
so we get ninja now let's call
obj1.speak
we could definitely have created this
speak function in the middle here
but i just copied it into place for each
of the objects
so obj1.speak what is the thing to the
left of the dot well it's obj1 so we get
doctor
object2.speak we get skywalker perfect
ninja dr skywalker let's do it again
but let's uh grab it out as a function
now in this case it's no longer the
thing to the left of the dot
or rather the thing to the left of the
dot is global
so obj1.speak will work correctly we'll
get doctor
auggs.speak will get undefined we didn't
define
a global name
so let's create a new mechanism where we
can go grab a button
now we grab it by id and then we click
the button
to call the speak function now what's
the thing to the left of the dot
well it's the button so when i say this
dot id
knowing that i have a get element by id
i'm going to output
the button perfect
now what if we want to change the speak
function to output the name
in 100 milliseconds instead okay
so let's do it now when we call
obj1.speak
settimeout is going to create a whole
new stack
so what is this in this new stack well
it's the global function so we're going
to get ninja twice
let's see if we can fix that we can
alter what
this means by calling dot call
now we'll say dot call and we'll pass
in what we want this to be
so taking a look at this code obj1.speak
obviously works as expected
but we don't have a speak function in
object2 so we'll say obj1.speak.call and
set this to be obj2
now this is set to be obj2 we've
overridden it
and so we'll get doctor and skywalker
great well let's do that same mechanism
we'll say dot
call this to try and fix our problem
here with
our set timeout now
it's going to say dot call but this
executes it right away
so we will get the right answer ninja
and doctor but we didn't wait the
necessary 100 milliseconds
let's look at bind now bind is a great
way to create a closure a new function
that has
this set the way we expect we can kind
of think of it like this
this isn't the correct syntax but we can
think of it this way let's pass in a
function and what we want this to be
we'll return a new function we'll say
function.call
with that set now we have this new
function that we can call whenever we're
ready
and that will actually do the function
calling
so let's look at the real syntax
obj1.speak.bind
obj2 okay so because we're saying
bind we get this new obj2speak function
and we can call it later and this is
already bound to obj2
so we get doctor and skywalker perfect
now we'll probably see in our code
obj2.speak.bind2 a lot
what it's trying to do is saying i want
to set this i don't want any ambiguity
that's perfect if you find that in your
code that's exactly what it's doing
now let's come back to our set timeout
function and let's call dot bind
this now that bind this will return a
new function that we can call later
say in 100 milliseconds so now that we
called dot bind
well we've got ninja and doctor it works
correctly
very nice now let's
change to an arrow function now what an
arrow function does
is it binds the variables at the point
where the function is defined we can
think of it kind of like this
so let's define this function bind it
the way we expect
and let's see how this goes so we've got
this speak function and we'll turn it
into an arrow function
now because it binds at the point where
it's created
then well this is bound
to the global scope at the point where
it's created
we get ninja ninja ninja oops
that isn't what we expected okay so
let's say object2.speak.bindobj2 we have
this trick that allows us to bind this
well kind of this is already bound into
place
so wrapping it in another function that
binds it to something else
then when it calls this inner function
it's already bound so we can't
re-bind it so yeah
nope that didn't work okay so here
in our function let's use an arrow
function here we know that it binds at
the point where it's created
so let's use that to grab this
and now yes ninja doctor it works as
expected
perfect now what if we changed speak
to be an arrow function well then it
wouldn't behave as expected
now it would bind to the global this but
because we have this outer one as
function and this inner one is an arrow
function it behaves as expected
now that's a little weird knowing that
arrow functions bind at the point where
they're created
will help us to understand a little bit
about how it works
we shouldn't just change every function
to be an arrow function
that would be well to bind this too much
and we've seen that we can't override it
now let's briefly take a look at the
event loop i
love this website where we get to look
at how the event loop works
let's open this in a new tab and flip
over to that tab
and we can take a look at this this
video is awesome
now we have some code here and we have
the call stack what it's running right
now
a callback queue and web apis for
example
i'm waiting for a database or a rest
call to complete
so let's copy this code and we'll go set
it in place
and take a look at how it works save and
run
now we start out with that set timeout
okay now it's counting
for i equals one to three and it's
counting and
it's setting new content up here to
finish
once that finishes it comes back down
here into the callback queue
that as the call stack empties it goes
and grabs the next thing from the
callback queue
and sets it in place now this highlights
that great
scenario where what is it outputting
well it's outputting the current i
what is the i by the time it gets here
well
it's um three
so we're gonna console log three three
times
but we get a sense for the call stack
the callback queue
web apis it is a perfect mechanism for
being able to visualize those three
pieces
i would invite you to play with that
site because it is really really fun
so we've got that stack where as the
content is run
it's going to run through all of the
pieces in the stack it's not going to
look at anything in the callback queue
until the stack is empty
once the stack is empty it will grab the
next piece from the callback queue and
set it on the stack
and process it read more or watch more
about this and learn some more about it
now as we look at node we can think of
it like this
now this isn't the physical layout but
this is a good logical layout each
request has its own
stack and callback queue and the things
that it's waiting for
now as as node goes through it looks at
each request and gets it a little bit
farther
well what if this request is going to
count from one to a billion
well then the the callback queue can't
get further
so we'll not we'll want to do a lot of
things to get to yield the thread
as much as possible so that the other
tasks have a
a chance to get caught up and then we'll
come back and
and compute a few more
so we might see something like this set
timeout zero
why would i wait zero seconds well
because we're trying to yield the thread
so that the rest of the quests can get
caught up
we might also do this process.next tick
and in more modern versions of node we
don't even need the empty
function here we can just say await
process dot next tick
and now we've yielded the thread for a
second and let
everybody else catch up that is perfect
now if there's no other requests that
need any attention it will come back to
us nearly immediately and continue on
async can await now we only have a
minute so let's cruise through this
really fast async and await was clearly
borrowed
from c sharp it builds a similar state
machine
as
as the task parallel library in c-sharp
but it does it with promises
and generators
so what if we have this promise based
library here and we want to upgrade some
of the things to async and await
how do we do that well the cool part is
that async and await
has this mechanism where we can just
await things and start to feel
as if it was synchronous that's amazing
now because it feels synchronous we can
start to think about it
with you know standard fallback
mechanisms but we know it'll stop here
until this is done and it'll stop here
until this is done
and it's not blocking the thread it's
yielding the thread for other things
and then when it comes back then it'll
be able to continue on
we can think a lot more synchronously in
spite of the fact that it's actually
executing asynchronously that's amazing
now do we have to wait until we do a big
bang refactor to get everything
nope async and await works as promises
under the hood
so we have this async function and let's
call it but not
await it what is res well res is a
promise that we can just dot
then with now we could choose to await
it so that we would resolve the promise
but knowing that it is a promise under
the hood we could
dot then so let's imagine that i have
this
legacy function that i need to call from
this new async code that i'm writing
do i have to use promises and a dot then
athon
no i can just well await
that function i know how to await
promises
and it works just fine simultaneously
if we go the other way then we can take
a look at this
async function and call it using
promises now in this case we would like
to do a lot of things in parallel
now we want to call lib1 column 2.
notice how we're not
awaiting them so we have three promises
well how do we await a bunch of promises
we have this promise.all
and we can await that and then we have
all our results
all these things happen simultaneously
well kind of javascript is still
single threaded but i didn't have to
wait for one to finish before i started
two
that's perfect javascript it's an
amazing experience for a 10-day project
25 years ago
i think brendan ike did an amazing job
the code i wrote 25 years ago is not
nearly as good as the code he wrote 25
years ago
find me in that place that the
conference has designated for q
a or if you're watching this later hit
me up on twitter at rob underscore ridge
you can grab the slides right now from
robrich.org
thanks for watching